o imán o una madre,
cuando me llaman después de que un oficial dispara a otro niño negro desarmado,
entiendo un poco del dolor en su voz.
Es el dolor de un corazón roto cuando no resuelve un problema mortal.
Dejar de intentar hacer algo
que parece necesario e imposible a la vez.
La forma en que se trata de solucionar el racismo suele percibirse
como necesario e imposible.
A los jefes de policía les gusta hablar conmigo porque soy experto,
pero dudo que hicieran cola para echarse en el sofá del Dr. Phil
si les dijera que todos sus problemas no tienen remedio.
Toda mi investigación,
y la década de trabajo que he hecho en mi centro,
el Centro para la Equidad Policial,
en realidad me lleva a una conclusión esperanzadora
en medio de la angustia sobre la raza en EE. UU.
que es:
resolver el racismo parece imposible
porque nuestra definición de racismo lo hace imposible,
pero no tiene por qué ser así.
Esto es lo que quiero decir.
La definición más común de racismo
es que los comportamientos racistas
son el producto de corazones y mentes contaminados.
Cuando escuchamos la forma como hablamos sobre curar el racismo,
oirán:
"Necesitamos acabar con el odio.
Necesitamos combatir la ignorancia". ¿Verdad?
Son corazones y mentes.
El único problema con esa definición es que es completamente errónea:
tanto científicamente como de cualquier otra manera.
Uno de los aprendizajes fundamentales de la psicología social,
es que las actitudes son predictores muy débiles de comportamientos,
pero más importante que eso,
ninguna comunidad negra ha salido a las calles
para exigir que los blancos nos quieran más.
Las comunidades marchan para detener la matanza,
porque el racismo son comportamientos, no sentimientos.
E incluso cuando los líderes de los Derechos Civiles
como King y Fannie Lou Hamer usaron el lenguaje del amor,
el racismo que combatieron
fue segregación y brutalidad.
Son acciones sobre los sentimientos.
Y cada uno de esos líderes estaría de acuerdo,
si una definición de racismo que hace más difícil ver
las lesiones que causa el racismo,
eso no solo es un error.
Una definición que se preocupa por las intenciones de los abusadores,
más que por los daños a los maltratados,
esa definición de racismo es racista.
Pero cuando cambiamos la definición de racismo de actitudes a comportamientos,
transformamos ese problema de imposible a solucionable.
Porque se pueden medir los comportamientos.
Y si puedes medir un problema,
puedes aprovechar una de las únicas reglas universales del éxito organizacional.
Tienes un problema o una meta, lo mides,
uno se hace responsable de esa métrica.
Y, si cualquier otra organización mide el éxito de esta manera,
¿por qué no podemos hacer eso en lo poliacial?
Resulta que en realidad ya lo hacemos.
Los departamentos de policía ya practican la rendición de cuentas basada en datos.
Esto se hace solo para el crimen.
La gran mayoría de los departamentos de policía en EE. UU.
usa un sistema llamado CompStat.
Es un proceso que, cuando se usa bien,
identifica datos de delitos,
los rastrea e identifica patrones,
y luego permite que los departamentos se hagan responsables
de los objetivos de seguridad pública.
Funciona dirigiéndose a atenciones policiales y recursos policiales,
o a cambiar el comportamiento de la policía una vez que aparecen.
Si veo una serie de atracos en ese vecindario
querré aumentar las patrullas en ese vecindario.
Si veo un aumento en los homicidios,
querré hablar con la comunidad para averiguar por qué y así
colaborar en el cambio del comportamiento policial para frenar la violencia.
Cuando se define el racismo en términos de comportamientos medibles,
se puede hacer lo mismo.
Se puede crear un CompStat para la justicia.
Eso es exactamente lo que ha hecho el Centro para la Equidad Policial.
Les diré cómo funciona.
Después de que un departamento de policía nos invita a entrar,
manejamos los asuntos legales, nos relacionamos con la comunidad.
Nuestro siguiente paso es analizar sus datos.
El objetivo de estos análisis es determinar
cuánto predice la delincuencia, la pobreza, la demografía del vecindario
el uso policial de la fuerza.
Digamos que si esos factores predicen
la policía usará la fuerza sobre esta cantidad de personas negras.
¿Estamos?
Y nuestra siguiente pregunta es:
¿Cuántas personas negras son realmente objetivo
para el uso policial de la fuerza?
Digamos que son tantos.
Entonces, ¿qué pasa con la brecha?
Una gran parte de la brecha es la diferencia
entre lo que predicen las cosas que la policía no puede controlar
y lo que predice la policía que puede controlar:
sus políticas y sus comportamientos.
Y lo que estamos buscando son los tipos de contacto
o las zonas de la ciudad
donde esa brecha es mayor,
porque entonces podemos decir a nuestros socios,
"Mira aquí. Resuelve este problema primero".
En realidad es el tipo de terapia que los jefes de policía pueden respaldar,
porque no hay nada tan inspirador frente a nuestra historia de racismo
como un problema solucionable.
Si la comunidad en Minneapolis pidiera a su departamento de policía
remediar las fallas morales de raza en la vigilancia policial,
no estoy seguro de que supieran hacerlo.
Pero si en cambio la comunidad dice:
"Tus datos dicen que estás golpeando a muchas personas sin hogar.
Debes dejar de hacer eso".
Eso es algo que la policía puede aprender a hacer.
Y lo hicieron.
En 2015, la policía de Minneapolis nos hizo saber
que a su comunidad le preocupaba que usaran la fuerza con demasiada frecuencia.
Y les mostramos cómo aprovechar sus propios datos
para identificar situaciones en las que se podría evitar la fuerza.
Y al mirar esos datos,
se ve que un número desproporcionado de sus incidentes de uso de la fuerza,
involucró a alguien sin hogar, con angustia mental,
con un problema de abuso de sustancias o una combinación de las tres.
Mucho más de lo esperado
basado en esos factores de los que les estaba hablando.
Así que ahí está la brecha.
La siguiente pregunta es por qué.
Resulta que las personas sin hogar a menudo necesitan servicios.
Y si esos servicios no están disponibles, si no pueden obtener sus medicamentos,
pierden su lugar en el refugio,
entonces son más propensos a participar en comportamientos
donde al final la gente llama a la policía.
Y cuando aparece la policía,
son más propensos a resistir la intervención,
muchas veces porque en realidad no han hecho nada ilegal,
literalmente solo viven afuera.
El problema no era la necesidad de entrenar
a los oficiales de forma diferente en Minneapolis.
El problema era que la gente usaba a la policía
para "tratar" el abuso de sustancias y la falta de vivienda en primer lugar.
Y, la ciudad de Minneapolis encontró una manera
de brindar servicios sociales y recursos de la ciudad
a la comunidad de personas sin hogar antes de que alguien llamara a la policía.
(Aplausos)
Ahora el problema no siempre es la falta de vivienda, ¿verdad?
A veces el problema es el miedo a la aplicación de la ley de inmigración,
como en Salt Lake City, o en Houston,
donde los jefes tuvieron que presentarse
y decir: "No vamos a deportarlo solo por llamar al 911".
O el problema es la persecución a pie
como en Las Vegas donde
tuvieron que entrenar a sus oficiales para reducir la velocidad y respirar
en lugar de permitir que la adrenalina en esa situación se intensifique.
En las persecuciones en Oakland,
se saca a la gente de los autos en San José,
es la forma en que patrullan los barrios
que conforman la Zona 3 en Pittsburgh,
y los barrios negros más cercanos a la costa de Baltimore.
Pero en cada ciudad
si podemos darles un problema solucionable,
se ocupan de resolverlo.
Y juntos, nuestros socios han visto un promedio de un 25 % menos arrestos,
menos incidentes por uso de fuerza
y 13 % menos lesiones relacionadas con oficiales.
Esencialmente, al identificar las brechas más grandes
y dirigir la atención de la policía para resolverlo,
entregamos una vacuna basada en datos contra la disparidad racial en la policía.
En este momento tenemos capacidad de asociarnos con unas 40 ciudades a la vez.
Eso significa que si queremos que EE. UU. deje de sentirse exhausto
al tratar de resolver un problema imposible,
vamos a necesitar mucha más infraestructura.
Porque nuestro objetivo es que nuestras herramientas puedan escalar
la brillantez de organizadores dedicados
y jefes reformistas.
Para llegar allí necesitaremos la voluntad colectiva
que las escuelas desagregadas
ganaron para los hijos e hijas de antiguos esclavos,
para que podamos construir un tipo de sistema de salud
capaz de entregar nuestra vacuna en todo el país.
Porque nuestra idea audaz
es entregar un CompStat para la justicia
a departamentos que atienden a 100 millones de personas en EE. UU.
en los próximos cinco años.
(Aplausos)(Vítores)
Hacer eso significaría armar a un tercio de EE. UU. con herramientas
para reducir las disparidades raciales policiales
en detenciones, arrestos y uso de la fuerza.
Pero también herramientas para reducir la fianza depredadora
y encarcelamiento masivo,
inestabilidad familiar
y problemas crónicos de salud mental y abuso de sustancias,
y cualquier otra enfermedad que agrave nuestro sistema penal y legal.
Porque cada arresto innecesario que podamos prevenir
salva a una familia del aterrador viaje por cada uno de esos sistemas.
Al igual que cada arma que podemos dejar enfundada
salva a toda una comunidad de toda una vida de dolor.
Todos y cada uno de nosotros,
medimos las cosas que nos importan.
Las empresas miden ganancias,
buenos estudiantes llevan un registro de sus calificaciones,
las familias miden el crecimiento de sus hijos
con marcas de lápiz en marcos de puertas.
Todos medimos las cosas que más nos importan,
por eso sentimos la negligencia
cuando nadie se molesta en medir nada.
Durante el último cuarto de milenio,
hemos definido los problemas de raza y vigilancia policial
de una manera funcionalmente imposible de medir.
Pero ahora la ciencia dice que podemos cambiar esa definición.
Y la gente del Centro para la Equidad Policial,
en realidad, creemos haber medido
más comportamiento policial que cualquiera en la historia humana,
y eso significa que una vez que tengamos la voluntad
y los recursos para hacerlo,
esta podría ser la generación
que deje de sentir que el racismo es un problema sin solución,
y en cambio vea
que lo que ha sido necesario durante demasiado tiempo es posible.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)(Vítores)